all right the book three women is one of
the summers most anticipated debuts
author Lisa Tadeo spent eight years
traveling the crunch the country to
share the stories of three different
women's sexual desires Lena is an
Indiana housewife who says she is in a
loveless marriage and has an affair
Sloane Owens a Rhode Island restaurant
with her chef husband and says she has
an open marriage and Maggie is in North
Dakota and says she was underage when
she had a relationship with her married
English teacher a jury acquitted the
accused teacher of three charges and a
judge dismissed the last two charges
three women is published by avid reader
press that's an imprint of Simon &
Schuster a CBS company Lisa
Tadeo joins us at the table thank you
for being here thank you for having me
so one of the questions with you is like
what are her qualifications and my exit
qualifications are nearly a decade of
reporting crisscrossing in the country
moving you to talents to spend time with
these people it you put fliers up in
restaurants and bars interviewed
hundreds of people about their their
their state of desire what did you learn
I learned that we're all united in our
passion and and how much how much we
hide it and how much we don't want to
talk about it and I think that desire is
something we think about so often and
it's also the thing that we hold most
closely to our chest so I wanted to
explore the nuance of that intersection
you say we but this is not a book about
we this is not about women why'd you
exclude men I didn't exclude them I am I
started by talking to both men and women
I spoke to hundreds of each gender but
it just became I started to be more
interested in the complexity of female
desire which I found to just have a lot
more prismatic and complex feelings
attached to it I wouldn't know what a
simple machine I think I want to know
what your fliers said what was your page
to get people is there a difference
between desire and sex what did your
Flyers say to get people to talk to you
my Flyers you know I made them in a
Staples in Santa Barbara so they were
not exactly the most elegant of things
they said you know unrequited love
question mark they were all different do
you have a compelling story of desire if
so you know email me at
and I got you know a number of
interesting emails and none of the
actual people that I profiled came from
the Flyers but I learned a lot from that
dude what's the difference that desert
or is there a difference yeah I think
there's absolutely a difference I think
that sex you know is intact and and
people are very comfortable often in
describing the act it's easy to talk
about it in the sense but because it's
mechanical a lot of the time but when it
comes to desire it's a matter of talking
about the very difficult and interesting
emotions that come that are behind sex
and I find that women were more
articulate and describing those I've
read this book over the fourth of July
and I couldn't put it down
and one of the things that really struck
me were the three men women that you
ended up choosing is that that each of
them ultimately they their desire was
secret any in each case in a form and
they were ultimately punished for it yes
mm-hmm
what does that tell you well that's such
a good observation so true yeah from a
guy you know it was one of the the most
one of the biggest commonalities between
the three women who were vastly
different was that they were all judged
by their communities in ways that were
remarkable and they weren't really doing
anything completely outside of the norm
but because they were slightly aberrant
it was easy for people to judge them I'm
surprised at that judgment yes it was
shocking I mean I was shocking on you
know a number of different levels for
Sloane who is the entrepreneur in the
northeast of one of the first rumors I
heard about her was that her husband
wanted to be intimate with her every day
and not only did she allow it but she
enjoyed it and this they were the one
who he also enjoyed watching her have
sex with other men and they enjoyed
photographing videotaping yes you know
and were different kind of couples yeah
it was different but what I will say is
it was one of the happiest marriages
that I observe are they still together
they are and they're very
extraordinarily happy but what's
interesting is that you can imagine that
man telling talking about his marriage
or becoming public and not being
embarrassed by the details of it but the
woman might feel differently so this go
to the point that men are very open in
pursuing whatever they desire and women
as you write in the prologue they often
subvert their desire on an hourly basis
yes why I think it's just it's easier
for four centuries we've been ok you
know the male the state of male desire
is accepted whereas the state of female
desire is largely is largely told by
what the men want and obviously this is
changing in remarkable ways and with the
me to movement we're finally saying well
we don't want but I do think as women
we're not really expressing what we do
want because there is a very quiet
judgment underlying everything with you
wrote this largely or you researched it
largely before the me - yes correct
really developed you don't really
mention the me - no well you know
because I well one of the reasons as you
said was that it was largely researched
and reported prior but the other thing
was that I I was really wanting to
explore what we do want and what we
can't talk about and I think there's
enough out there about what we don't
talk about but I think what we do talk
about is so strikingly important what
was fascinating to me - Lisa's away you
wrote it because it reads like a novel
yes I kept going back and more thing
this is true this really happened I mean
was that a deliberate clearly a
deliberate choice on your part because
it reads like a novel
well you know it was a choice in the
sense that I I wanted to I wanted it to
be really honest and so I asked these
women the same question hundreds of
times I spent you know I would spend two
hours dissecting one text message so you
know I went often I would go to like
with Lena where she was intimate with
Aidan the man from high school with
stratospherically obsessed very
passionate very passionate in a truck in
a truck yes and so I would go to the
spot after she'd been intimate with him
at this river and I would just sit there
and take in the smells and the sound so
I could layer those it feels like you're
living inside these woman's thought
they're having today oh thank you three
women fascinating books on sale now